considering the past and how long you
guys were together obviously I'm sure
this is a difficult question but are you
at peace with things yet I mean and how
are you grieving and getting over the
loss of the love of your life well it's
taken a lot of therapy it's taken um I
have an amazing grief counselor that
helped me get through this the loss of
Alan and the way he passed away it was
just so shocking we were planning on
expanding the family I just started the
nursery upstairs and so when I lost him
it was not just it was my whole life
just came shattering down it just
shattered and my hair fell out my
eyebrows fell out my lashes fell out the
kind of grieving and stress that I went
through the worst had happened losing
Alan was it the worst so everything else
that followed was second what followed
was a lawsuit five months after Alan's
death his adult son singer Robin Thicke
and his brother Brennan filed a lawsuit
against Tonya claiming she planned to
contest her prenup with Alan that
lawsuit made absolutely no sense because
they filed it 24 hours before my
expiration time to contest the prenup
they just had to wait 24 hours and there
was nothing I could do the lawsuit was
tossed out in September when a judge
declared there was no evidence that
Tonya wanted to challenge the contract
which among other things allowed her to
live in the ranch she shared with Alan
in his will however Alan made his sons
the property owners I am so grateful to
my husband to have been able to to give
me my sanctuary here and thank God my
attorney solidified my sanctuary here
where I get to live here for the rest of
my life but I also have to pay for all
the expenses including the mortgage and
the upkeep in order to stay here and I
still haven't gotten anything from the
boys as far as a distribution plan or an
accounting for the estate and it's been
one year in four months and I have been
very patient because I really want to
keep the peace out of love and respect
for Alan is it difficult to be here
mean this house must be full of memories
in it oh but that's what I love about it
I feel my husband's presence in this
house this is a house that I've now
lived in for almost 20 years how do you
move on
I haven't yet because this man gave me
the love that I had never felt in my
life and for that I will I will forever
be indebted to my husband and I still
miss him and I visit him every Tuesday
because I made a tombstone for him and
white marble so I make it a point to go
out and visit him every week so I can
clean it because it's white you got to
keep on cleaning that white marble I I
don't want to see anything on my
husband's tombstone I want it perfect
who's been your rock because I mean
everything seems so isolating you know
my rock has really been my incredible
girlfriends Kris Jenner was here to lift
me out during the memorial party that
took place before I even buried Allen
I've had friends who are great these are
those crazy friends that I don't respond
to half the time that are like oh my god
so-and-so was asking about you wants to
take you on a date and I'm like how
disrespectful to my husband he doesn't
want me on a date
it's the last thing on my mind how dare
you Terran bike hang up but do you think
you're gonna ever find love again
I don't think so I'll be honest with you
Matt I don't think so I think that when
you have love this profoundly and this
deeply it's gonna take a really long
time and I'm okay with that
and my husband gave me
much love that I don't need love from
anyone else I'm good